[Musique]
priori tout se passe super bien sur le
tapis rouge de ce soixante quatorzième
festival de cannes c'était une soirée
particulière puisque c'était la soirée
de benedetta le fils de paul verhoeven
avec virginie efira on a parlé sur
toutes les clés du film les invités du
festival
regardez ça oui l'ambiance et comment
aujourd'hui c'est notre première réunion
de jury c'était super c'était formidable
de pouvoir comment les tous très
différents avec notre façon de réfléchir
au québec
j'avais très inspirant ah oui tout à
fait hier soir sandrine rebecca vous
avez présenté jeudi matin à la semaine
de la critique quand ça s'est passé
c'était merveilleux c'était une émotion
est très bas à part ça tout le film
quand j'étais toute seule dans région en
train d'imaginer plus de propulser l'âge
et jetterait frère de m
vous rêvez cas vous revenir bleus la
semaine prochaine ce qui est des
pêcheurs y compris vous n'avez ans je
serai pas là malheureusement sur mon
combat est fini pour les faire aussi
vive on le sait on le sent pour nous
l'important
ajoutez à cela
re lancement du débat c'est
ce bel élan
mais revanche spéciales étaient fermés
voilà aux lakers les saxons et rouge les
acomptes dès maintenant et ça m'a aidé à
vous êtes là pour présenter à la section
environnementale du festival marché sur
route et un documentaire que j'ai tourné
au niger pendant un an dans une
communauté villageoise qui aujourd'hui
en raison du réchauffement climatique
fait face à un manque d'eau absolument
terrible et le fait que le site festival
de cannes créé cette section éphémère si
les mains pour le climat c'est un parent
ne fait de prix une section comme ça
j'espère que ça m'a inspiré
les dirigeants du suv
ça permettra des films qui abordent de
façon artistique ces questions-là
crucial de voile avec de plus en plus
présent de plus en plus visible wadoux
c'est votre première fois à cannes pour
star du rap sur le tapis rouge du
festival de cannes ça te fait quoi
écoutez je suis honoré je suis honoré de
pouvoir être là d'avoir été invité je
suis honoré de monter ses marges que
j'ai vu bébé et donc voilà je suis tout
excité vous avez ainsi bientôt car il
sait exactement exactement le pays tout
ça de temps elle va démarrer à la fin
juillet et voilà je suis je suis content
de vous l'annoncer aujourd'hui avec
lille ce dernier
on va produire un film comédie
romantique avec la pluie de canal plus
est
et voilà je ne peux pas trop court pour
raconter le film s'appelait il mis
d'accord et vous commencé quand vous
tournez qu'en fin juillet on commence le
tournage
daphné pataca qui est l'un des rôles
principaux de ce benedetta une
révélation de vouvant dans le film vous
vous attendiez à sable attendait à ce
que parce que inscrits devenu le film
non pas du tout bas quand on chante on
tourne un film on se projette pas
forcément dans mon histoire de comment
ça va quelle va être la carrière prend
pas prêt donc là je suis
tellement heureuse pour la dent mais ya
trois ans
monde de retrouver toute l'équipe du
tournage qui est venu à montréal
man show je prends que votre réalisateur
et là je suis donc avec paul verhoven le
réalisateur de bd d'état le film
présenté ce soir à cannes après un long
long long chemin
comment vous avez vécu tous ces
empêchements jusqu'à ce soir c'était
arrivé là c'est très étrange pour moi de
parler de ce film qui j'ai fait il ya
trop gens d'où vient benedetta tout bien
l'histoire d'où vient ce cette histoire
de nonne qui devient une folle de dieu
j'ai trouvé chab dans le petit livre qui
a été écrit par un écrivain américain
ouais professeur d histoire qui a trouvé
le note de 2
du crochet de pina d'état dans leur
genre qui faisait que l'on fera en 1984
écoutez ya votre benedetta qu'est la
chasse bénéteau c'est un des plus grands
réalisateurs du monde est d'accord pour
- oui c'est toujours d'ailleurs
oui mais ça l'était dès l'adolescence en
fait basique heatsink prévisibles estime
pew après j'ai découvert toute sa
filmographie américaine c'est plus tard
que j'ai découvert les films hollandais
mais ce qui s'inscrit dans l'adolescence
comme amour cinématographique je ne sais
pas pour vous mais ça ne change plus
jamais donc oui c'est quelque chose de
particulier d'avoir pu vivre c'est trois
mois de tournage absolument harmonieux
et intense avec d'avoir un cinéaste que
six jeunes mon dieu ça c'est quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel et c'est
d'ailleurs est aussi libre dans sa
manière de raconter les choses te
raconter des choses sérieuses profonde
intelligente avec toujours une forme du
loup aussi en connaissent aussi bien
qui est quand même 4e à merveille c'est
un cinéma j'ai enfin de divertissement
mais quand même accessible que moi c'est
ça que j'ai pensé de lui quand j'ai
découvert ces films une entrée possible
et qui ouvre sur pleinement de
différends sur un champ politique tout à
fait l'inversé
sur un champ esthétique 9 je suis deg
les merveilleux je crois que je peux te
voir vous laisser monter les mains de
virginie merci beaucoup d'être
formidable levier version steam sinon
rendez vous demain à 20h35 pour chit
chat spécial cannes et on saura comment
la dame est coiffé de bain
[Musique]